foreign
's been off to Western weapons for
months and months now tomorrow since the
beginning of the conflict but especially
for this coming counter-offensive
some of the most talked about weapon
systems coming from the West have been
the tanks Western tanks like The Leopard
2 that we've heard about the American
Abrams and the UK Challenger too so
these tanks not only are they modernize
they have a combination of extremely
heavy protective armor they have the
ability to be able to fight at night
which is extremely important they have
upgraded Electronics Suites to be able
to detect enemy tanks at a greater
distance you've got a really potent
effective weapon there
but what they need to do is also keep
their inventory safe these are wide open
spaces subject to all artillery strikes
they will use infantry fighting Vehicles
like the striker like the Bradley to be
able to protect their own troops and
also provide Firepower as well now on
top of that you will need air cover and
you will need drones the Ukrainian
request for fighter jets although it
looks like it's starting to go through
well they won't be arriving anytime soon
so they'll have to fight with what they
have in the meantime
obviously their own Air Force plus
donations of mig-29s Russian aircraft
that they know how to fly you will also
have an influx of Turkish drones armed
drones by the way we're not talking
these small DJI drones that are designed
to spot artillery also important and
could very well be a game changer is the
donation by the United Kingdom of the
Storm Shadow cruise missile it's a
stealthy cruise missile it has the
ability to deliver a warhead just under
half a ton with pinpoint accuracy at
three times the range of high miles and
there's also a tandem charge so it's two
explosives in one the first charge
detonates on contact blows a hole in a
hardened structure and the second charge
goes through that hole and detonates
inside destroying everything
something that needs to be mentioned
artillery by both sides by the way and
they're sourcing it from wherever they
can because even a defensive operations
either side is expending 5 000 rounds a
day in specific battle that's an awful
lot of ammunition when you add it up and
you'll probably need triple that amount
if you're going to go on the offensive
[Music]